les centres commerciaux sont ils menacés
de disparition
afin de tenter de freiner la hausse de
leur taux d'inoccupation plusieurs
centres commerciaux cherchent des
solutions innovantes pour demeurer en
vie
j'en ai discuté hier avec jacques nantel
professeur émérite hec montréal
comment est ce qu'on explique cette
hausse au cours des dernières années du
taux d'inoccupation dans les centres
commerciaux cette désaffection dans les
centres commerciaux
il ya un maître mot un commerce
électronique savait au moment où on se
parle que ce soit ici aux etats unis
c'est pratiquement 13% des espaces
commerciaux qui sont maintenant vacant
ça a été progressif ça a été progressif
au exactement au même rythme où la
consommation est partie des centres
commerciaux pour sont allés sur
l'internet sur le web a aujourd'hui au
moment où on se parle au québec c'est
pratiquement 10% des produits que l'on
achète que l'on achète sur le web ce qui
est affiché sur le web n'est plus
achetés en magasin et la situation des
détaillants est telle que si vous perdez
10 % de vos ventes
vous avez souvent plus les moyens de
payer le loyer que vous payez donc on
s'en va vers de nouvelles formules et ça
libère beaucoup d'espacé commercial et
la situation des centres commerciaux aux
états unis je crois est bien pire que
celle qu'on connaît ici au couteau deux
centres commerciaux aux états unis tout
à fait en fait aux états unis où on se
parle c'est 13% de tout vacances ici si
vous regardez pour l'ensemble du québec
on tablera 9%
malheureusement la même tendance existe
ici est ce que c'est la même situation
pour tous les types de commerces et de
détaillants dans les centres commerciaux
et pour tous les types de centres
commerciaux aussi
non en fait les plus affectés si on
parle du québec ce sont ce qu'on appelle
les centres régionaux donc les gros
centres commerciaux tels qu'on les a
conçu et développé au cours des années
70 80 les suprarégionaux par exemple le
10 39 30 en autant qu'ils offrent
beaucoup de produits de divertissement
la restauration théâtre baroque cinéma
passe à travers relativement bien ce
qu'ils gagnent en ce moment ça peut
sembler étonnant ce sont les petits
centres locaux souvent parce que on a
encore besoin d'un dépanneur on a besoin
de nettoyage forcément ce sont des
services
mais beaucoup de ces centres commerciaux
commencent à se repositionner en offrant
la possibilité pour
consommateurs d'aller chercher ces colis
envoyés par amazon ou un autre détail et
il ya des centres commerciaux qui se
spécialise aussi dans un type de
commerce qui était moins affecté la part
le commerce en ligne des commerces ou
des endroits où on offre des services
sont pas disponibles en ligne
forcément tout ce qui est service vous
allez leur demande où est le jus menace
le décret on en a parlé et flamands
absent de coiffure ça votre soi mais
rajouter à ça également l'alimentation
qui pour l'instant n'est pas encore tout
à fait affectés ou très affecté vous
allez retrouver effectivement ce qu'on
trouve en matière de centres de local
maintenant l'alimentation c'est la
prochaine frontière pour le commerce
électronique
et justement il y en a qui misent sur
l'alimentation qui se disent bon pour
attirer la clientèle nous la retenue on
va augmenter à améliorer notre offre
alimentaire on va faire toutes sortes de
petits kiosques pour vendre des produits
ça s'est répandue beaucoup ce concept
leur récemment ouais ça sera pas
beaucoup et je pense que c'est une bouée
de sauvetage à court terme parce que il
ya tout l'impact l'expérience ouais
c'est plaisant d'aller passer je prends
cet après midi dans un marché où ce qui
serait proche de marchés publics mais
n'en faites attention parce que en
contrepartie si beaucoup de produits que
l'on achetait de manière usuelle en
épicerie je pense à des nouilles sèche
là une boîte de tomates
on n'a pas besoin vraiment d'aller en
magasin on se doute bien que la
prochaine boîtes de nouilles aux va
ressembler à la dernière qu'on a acheté
et ce genre de produit commence de plus
en plus être acheté sur internet se le
faire livrer simplement parce que aucun
risque alors comment les centres
commerciaux peuvent t'ils remplacer les
grandes enseignes qui ont quitté les
espaces non parents passent à target cgt
comment on fait pour remplacer celle ci
pour meubler ses grands espaces
lorsqu'une façon il ya deux éléments
dans ce que vous dans votre question le
premier élément c'est par la diversité
on s'envoie de plus en plus vous l'avez
mentionné vers les services vers
l'expérience vers encore certains
produits mais pas nécessairement pour
les vendre pour les montres et donc
beaucoup plus des boucles des vitrines
pour montrer le produit et met le
deuxième élément c'est que lorsque l'on
fait la sommation tout seul - ce qui
passe pour le commerce électronique
c'est mathématique on a trop de pieds
carrés et donc
pur style de l'offre alimentaire c'est
pas nécessairement la solution puis les
concessionnaires automobiles non plus à
court terme c'était très court terme
notre alimentaire à moins qu'elle soit
vraiment tels que les gens veuillent se
battre pour aller l'essayer
puis encore ça durera pas nécessairement
très longtemps progressivement oui ça va
passer de plus en plus par le web mais
je retrouve automobile saab automobile
quand vous regardez l'évolution ben on a
de très gros groupes maintenant qui se
sont constitués qui ont investit
beaucoup en immobilier qui commencent à
se regrouper déjà progressivement pour
une région comme montréal
vous allez avoir dans un centre
commercial ou à l'extérieur
vous allez avoir l'équivalent de vrais
deux ou trois grands salons automobiles
en permanence où vous allez avoir tous
les modèles que vous voudrez choisir
puis généralement sur les taux mais un
concessionnaire qui offre si on pense
maintenant au commerce de proximité dans
les artères commerciales la mairesse de
montréal a annoncé cette semaine la
tenue de consultations pour voir qu'est
ce qui va pas avec les artères
commerciales
le taux d'inoccupation qui est de plus
en plus élevées à certains endroits est
ce que c'est la même dynamique c'est la
même problématique c'est malheureusement
pas la même dynamique c'est beaucoup
plus complexe
un centre commercial d'un point de vue
technique il ya un patron ou un
investisseur et un gestionnaire de
centre commercial sera pas dit que c'est
plus facile mais au moins on a une marge
de manoeuvre
lorsque vous parlez d'une artère
commerciale c'est terriblement atomisé
vous avez plusieurs propriétaires qui ne
sont pas nécessairement les mêmes que
les commerçants dont vous avez des
propriétaires qui peut vouloir être sur
une artère commerciale pour des fils
fins de spéculation
vous avez une municipalité qui table qui
établit sa fiscalité en grande partie
sur les revenus de ces commerçants vous
avez le commerçant qui essaient de tirer
son épingle du jeu et tous souhaitent en
relais de tomber progressivement un peu
comme une chaîne de dominos mais la
municipalité justement peut avoir un
rôle à jouer
d'autres sur les taxes sur les zonages
tout ça est ce qui a quelque chose à
faire ou si c'est peine perdue non c'est
pas peine perdue mais je pense que je
pense que deux deux écueils à éviter le
premier écueil c'est de croire que tout
va être réglé par une fiscalité moins
gourmandes
si vous enlevez ce qualité très
gourmande à montréal sans aucun doute
mais même si voulant levier au complet
ça ne réglerait pas le problème des
commerçants l'autre problème pour la
municipalité c'est que et comme je le
mentionnais ils ont pas nécessairement
tous les leviers ce qu'il faut faire
c'est plus que ce que la mairie ce plan
annoncé c'est c'est de s'asseoir et de
réfléchir correctement chaque artère
commerciale peut avoir un rôle défini
mais encore faut-il l'intégrer dans un
environnement à la fois social et
commercial décider ce que l'on veut
faire beaucoup nos artères commerciales
à montréal sont des artères qui ont été
conçus dans les années 50 pour offrir du
commerce de destination et puis comment
ils vont partir de pierrefonds pour
aller sur la rue saint denis par contre
la rue saint denis si on prend celle là
elle est enclavée dans un des quartiers
à plus forte densité au canada qui
s'appelle le plateau mont royal
donc si on commence à basculer son
commerce qui était d'un commerce de
destinations vers du commerce de
proximité
on peut y arriver wellington était
arrivé fleury est arrivé ce ne sont pas
toutes les artères commerciales qui
souffrent mais encore faut-il avoir la
volonté d'orienter sa dans la bonne
direction
il ya une réflexion à faire là dessus
jacques nantel merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue
merci